foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
go back to the break room our daily
nerdy news show and keep you updated on
everything you want to know uh coming up
on today's episode kit Harrington talks
eternals when will we go to wakanda on
Disney plus when are the Russo Brothers
in a hurry to rejoin the MCU and lots of
secret Invasion news speculation casting
all that kind of stuff with me here
today to dive into all these topics
we've got Erica wusu hey internet we've
got Jessica Clemens
and Brandon Barry hello I'm Zach
Huddleston and we're all thrilled to be
here on this lovely in in Los Angeles a
rainy Wednesday yeah but we're not in
Los Angeles so anyway
yes Wichita it's nice out we could be in
the sword space station we don't know I
put a hard W on swords
uh Hey and uh thank you to everybody
that's already in the chat and the super
chat's coming in Christian
unpronounceable thank you uh for every
hundred dollars we hit in super chat
today we will go on a R-rated Tire Aid
where we will turn all of James
Cameron's films into porn parodies okay
we do exactly 60 seconds of porn parody
titles of the entire James Cameron ubra
he hasn't he hasn't made that many
movies
but he's done so much things that we can
also make fun of them who might get into
his producer yeah didn't he recently
just talk more trash on Marvel yes he's
out there being salty as hell on his
press tour for Avatar weight of the
water so in
um yeah seawater so I'll do this is
drinking now the Titanic Water if James
Cameron's like nagging on uh the MCU
gets us like a full sex scene I'm all
for it in the MCU yeah oh I was like we
already got
MCU characters most likely to get full
on-screen sex scene I have like a full
sex scene existing like Hawkeyes
he's actually at least likely yeah yeah
because if she's in choke for him they
can do it all in CGI and nowhere but
that would cost so much money than the
prosthetic they have to make a digital
intimacy coordinator that's right okay
uh on two the headline
uh we want to start today with a
long-awaited update on the break room
Barbie watch uh we're of course BBW baby
we're obsessed with the Margot Roby see
mulu Ryan Gosling upcoming film from
Greta Gerwig
um in a feature for the Wall Street
Journal Margot Roby gave a little
insight into her approach to playing the
Title Character uh Roby chose the child
archetype for Barbie she didn't
elaborate beyond that so are we gonna
hear a baby voice no it's probably like
the mindset of like people think Barbie
is like they always are like oh Barbie's
like a dummy yeah a bimbo but it's like
she's also a scientist yeah she's a
Barbie girl in a Barbie world I'm not
familiar with that I do not know that
song that's a song you don't know that
song you want to see the musical oh
that's right you just missed it uh we
were we were speculating is this like a
weird like uh stanislavski method are
there are there 10 archetypes of actors
or of characters and she has chosen the
child they're like well you don't need
to do that you can either be the fool
yeah the child if you know what the
answer is please
you're welcome to come on the show too
but I'm sure you don't want to but we
will we will pull up all this set and
give you a full dance floor if you just
want to show off the dance routines you
learned for Barbie
um we we could be your venue for that
come on the show we break down some
cardboard boxes so you can break dance
on the break room
will do chat right now why is Tommy in
the chat and I also just want to say I
how
okay we'll talk about it later I want to
be approved by us to have a little right
wrench next to my name
yeah you got to earn that also real
quick uh with the Barbie news it's Roby
I thought it was Robbie at this whole
time oh I'm probably saying it wrong
however I said it's probably the wrong
way
I don't know I thought I was saying that
I'm glad someone did it I agree with you
it had it has one b in the script I
don't know if that's accurate or not I
think the bees are silent I think
in the chat in the chat Robbie Roby
um let's get a poll going is it Robbie
or Roblox what's that
fans waiting for an update on the Disney
plus wakanda spin-off uh we got some
disappointing news they're of course
doing the um your camera's really
exciting yeah yeah yeah I love seeing
you two next to each other on the camera
you guys look like little brothers
um uh well it's more like father son
because he was born in 2002. I was born
in 19. I was born in 1971. uh producer
Nate Moore uh of course one of the big
wigs over at Marvel uh did he's been
doing a lot of interviews lately on the
what kind of forever press tour and he
said um because of the amount of time
and attention that went into wakanda
forever and because of all the attention
that went into the upcoming ironheart
series it's also being produced by Ryan
coogler
um they're not as far along on the
wakanda spin-off Disney plus series
um so we'll see how far we can get about
with that
um yeah we've been assuming that's the
one that's been sometimes
I think there's also some speculation it
could kind of Follow That storyline of
the midnight angels that kind of break
off group from right you also had like
AO was a much more prominent character
in uh Falcon and Winter Soldier like
following her story and now we have like
Anika coming in uh yeah I don't know
this makes sense though we haven't heard
anything about this series
all the actors in the production staff
and the directors and writers are all
very busy now what comes out first this
show or armor Wars they're gonna push
armor so they can come out with the show
we'll get we'll get back to Don Cheadle
later in the show and we talk uh secret
Invasion
um oh on the Cinema Blend YouTube
channel uh the aforementioned Nate more
uh again he is getting out there that
guy is his checks today he is uh
promoting the hell out of this
um he confirmed that the upcoming uh
Disney Plus show ironheart is a direct
sequel to Black Panther wakanda forever
we had speculated on this show before a
little bit of like when that show would
be set at if like that this show might
be an origin story uh for Riri Williams
and her appearance in what kind of
forever is like she's already a couple
years deep you know what I mean like we
go back in time this is when he says
direct sequel to Black Panther walk on
forever they mean like timeline Wise
It's like when last or wherever we see
Riri Williams is picking up right at yes
ironheart yeah
I'm sorry oh yeah
wow
it's ghost reary with throughout
ironheart wow this magic and Technology
I don't know again for for those that
didn't catch you serious today Jessica
has seen wakanda forever no I haven't
well you can't talk about it and she
hasn't she's done a great job she's yet
to spoil us at all and she won't be
spoiling you today but um she has seen
the movie
um uh but I I like this too his wording
it's a direct sequel to Black Panther
what kind of forever does that also mean
we're gonna see some other black panther
wakanda forever actors characters in
Iron Heart it's possible I mean with the
footage they showed at d23 of iron heart
which still hasn't done filming uh they
said it in this interview also Nate
Moore was like it's almost done uh with
the filming of that show but it did look
like they were in a city they were in
either Chicago or Boston I don't know
where she's going to be based on that
series but it didn't you know didn't
seem like they were in wakanda at all
they didn't show anyone from wakanda in
the clips
or anything like that but it would be
interesting if someone comes over and uh
John where is ironheart again in the uh
uh sequence of Disney plus series Echo
is the very next one that we get well no
uh secret Invasion and then we get Echo
and then Loki season two and then Iron
Heart okay
after tomorrow so a full a full year
from now we got three Marvel series and
uh two films before then uh
but nice that they're almost done with
it they have plenty of time for the CGI
and all that stuff um okay in another
interview with uh Nate Moore again this
guy
he did he did clarify that what kind of
reference place in the Marvel timeline
uh is after no way home in eternals and
concurrent with Thor 11 Thunder and
Quantum
it was an insane thing for him to say
why okay explain why this is inside okay
we we at the channel we're very
concerned about the timeline for phase
four yes right 100 what's on Disney
Plus's uh chronological order timeline
is messed up and it's not right and I
will I will fight this till the day I
die uh but in this interview Nate Morris
kind of like uh he says well you know it
clearly takes place after nowhere home
and eternals which are two weird things
to check yeah because those are not
close to each other according to Disney
themselves well we don't know no way
home on the Disney line because right no
way home covers several months right it
starts at the end of far from home which
was the summer of 2024 and it ends with
the post-credits scene winter 2024
Christmas time going into 2025. most of
it takes place around like October we
think because of the Halloween
decorations applying for college like
that kind of stuff
uh but it's very confusing eternals we
don't really know when it takes place he
was a producer on eternals so it makes
sense for him to name check that film
but it's they have it listed like way
before when no way home would be taking
place on like that why is it crazy that
this would be concurrent with 11 Thunder
and quantumania well quantumania is on
the Thunder's so far apart on release
dates yeah why are they so close uh Thor
11 Thunder does it give us the season
it's like spring-ish I mean this is
something we were talking about too it's
like they film a lot of these in Georgia
so it's like who knows what time of year
it is I guess it looks very
Thunder and quantumania are supposed to
be overlapped here I well also you know
one thing about this is like when a
movie is taking place at the exact same
time as another movie you don't have to
reference the events of that movie right
you know what I mean because they're
happening at the same time
today so they don't have to be like what
you know in quantumania they don't have
to be like boy that Gore the god butcher
was a weirdo huh you know and they like
quantumania and really Thor right most
of the stuff is going to be happening
off world in a Timeless vacuum so yeah
so it doesn't really matter what time
it's taking place yeah uh you guys oh so
sorry no girlfriend please I just wanna
really quick I know I'm not in their
seat go to camera two for me
um I'm not in their seat but I just want
to remind you guys to like And subscribe
now and if you are watching share with
your friends get them to jump on so they
know what we're talking about too and
you won't be the only one having to
watch us you can watch with your friends
also we're so close to reaching that 100
barrier where I can spew all of the porn
puns I already have cemented in my mind
for James Cameron spew was a fun have
you picked there
um yeah Tommy's in the chat berating
people to like And subscribe Jessica did
it nice so hopefully whichever tactic
you respond to You'll I got the first
James Cameron uh pun James hamrin hello
yours for free
second one for free
James Cameron that's my father's name
call me James came on
hey I just ate lunch and now you don't
know what you're going next
speaking of uh upcoming Marvel films um
you know we've been wondering when
Infinity war and end game directors the
Russo Brothers might do another Marvel
film they're kind of coy about it in
interviews they sometimes mention things
um but Joe Russo had told variety we
won't be ready to do anything with
Marvel until the end of the decade
damn those guys have their next eight
years planned out aren't they working on
something they're working on something
they're talking about they've got the
they're making five gray men movies yes
every every they'll have a monthly Gray
Man film uh and Hercules uh Hemsworth
one in the desert what was that one
called extraction yeah
they have this big uh this huge project
of Amazon called like uh uh Kingdom or
something like that but anyways they're
busy guys but we were also stuck doing
Hercules the live action they're doing
live action Hercules yeah or well I
don't know if they're directing it but I
will say that they've been talking about
it a lot and they said that they're
following they're using Tick Tock as
their example and using it as
inspiration for the movie
although this was just Joe Russo uh
this morning pulls out of his newspaper
what I'm tired of splitting my chin yeah
that guy half finished pool in the
backyard I need the money I'll take that
Fantastic Four movie um and then finally
uh Black Knight actor kit Harrington you
have an update that more eternals plans
are in the works in an interview with
The Hollywood Reporter he said uh the
post-credits stuff you come back and uh
film them after the film's finished to
see what there could be a continuation
is obviously exciting uh he continued I
don't know anything further I know that
there are plans I think at some point
but I don't know what they are this is
pretty vague great great answer yeah
it is good he's not clearing his January
schedule out or anything like that
because they're going to start filming
also what was that post-credit film
filming for him like silently in a room
opening a box with a sword
on the beach just like hey what am I
doing can you hear me the ocean's left
the ocean's loud there I mean whatever
it is and you know you might have your
feelings about eternals uh Cory jandro
uh staunch eternals Defenders claims is
one of his favorites uh whatever your
feelings are I want to see more Black
Knight we didn't really get to see him
do anything it was never the black
knight
uh so whatever future eternals or
spin-off he watches his girlfriend get
sucked into space and was like huh all
right
I'll go back to the museum anyone else
at the park see this I got some uh
paperwork everyone's like we've seen it
wouldn't want to get arrested by the
police for my girlfriend disappeared
um we're gonna dive deep into secret
Invasion but first we want to shout out
the second season of the hit show DC's
Batman the audio Adventures which is out
now on HBO Max this is an audio uh piece
of work on HBO Max it might not be a
place you normally go to for audio only
but it's there it's fun it's great I've
listened to a little bit of it I'm
excited to finish it Gotham City it's a
seething cauldron of crime and
Corruption about to boil over
long shadow of two-faced in the Penguins
combined Criminal Minds
of passion and Terror uh this is uh
again that that that's their wording my
wording is that this Show's awesome you
should definitely check it out crazy
cast Jeffrey Wright boom Rosario Dawson
whoa Bradley Whitford
Gillian Jacobs almost nailed it almost
said Jillian that's not how you
pronounce your name Keenan Thompson what
of all that man Chris Parnell and Bobby
Moynihan three SNL Alum Keenan's still
on SNL when's that guy getting off that
they're all in this show um it kind of
is centered around uh Bobby Moynihan
actually plays the penguin uh it's uh
sending around these stories it's it's
not necessarily um in the exact same
universe as Matt Reeves Batman but it's
kind of drawing from some of the same
inspiration stream DC's Batman the audio
Adventures season two right now on HBO
Max we know you subscribed to HBO Max
for House of the dragon and White Lotus
and whatever else you're watching the
sex lives of college girls coming back
soon on November 17th I'm very excited
for this oh okay on it all right I do
not do you act on it I write fan fiction
tune in tune in to break room after dark
to get a little bit of that yeah
oh yeah I'd watch that show
um Don Cheadle is this oh discussion
time I didn't know I was going to get a
discussion today don't you know I had an
interview with Entertainment Weekly
recently where he discussed his
character of James Rhodes AKA War
Machine and what's next to explore you
guys here's a clip
haven't you seen me you do porn in that
one movie no right you know the movie
with with Mark Goldberg
um Boogie Nights Boogie Nights oh yes
yeah he didn't have any nudes crash
okay now we got the clip okay rebirth in
a way you know it's coming back to this
character but we've never gone to the
places that we're about to go to in the
show so I feel like we're in some ways
just getting to know him even after all
this time
so yeah
right because we were talking about this
at the office right it was like kind of
weird for him to like do this we're
gonna explore this character we don't
really know anything about uh you know
what his history is what his motivations
are what what drives him I mean sure we
don't know that about it even though
he's had so much screen time bro he's
always the second banana he's a buddy
he's a support character right banana
second banana okay second fiddle second
fiddle a second
banana planet that one works the second
banana sounds horrible because I always
throw away the second band I hate the
first one
we wasted lots of fruit I'll bring them
here I'm sorry okay uh but yeah it makes
us think that like he's setting us up
for a big reveal about roads yeah
because we have this secret Invasion
coming out right uh and we know he's
gonna be on the series and it makes us
Wonder like could is roads maybe like a
squirrel right is he a secret scroll
because in the clip they've released
from Secret Invasion that they had at
d23 it's it's Hammond Sam Jackson you
know Nick Fury talking and Nick Fury
thinks he's about to be like oh there's
squirrel's surprise but Don Cheadle you
know Rhodes is like we actually know
they're skulls that we've known for like
18 years that they've been around so
it's kind of like this big reveal uh of
that like he's in on it not in on it but
is aware of it the pentagon's aware of
it they know of this problem uh and it's
gonna boil over so I made us think as we
prepare for secret Invasion should we
kind of do like a little mini explainer
of the secret Invasion run in the comics
and how that could Port over to the MCU
absolutely uh barely know anything about
it right it was a long it was a long
kind of uh you know multi-arc
multi-story multi-comic event that was
really well done by Marvel uh if you
haven't read it and you have Marvel
unlimited go check it out uh it's pretty
cool especially because they planted
seeds years ahead of time they did some
some great planning and they're like
we're gonna have this pay off much later
we're like characters that we thought
had died years before were actually
replaced by Scrolls and like all this
crazy stuff and it kind of in the comics
the Scrolls motivation here is like
they've lost their Homeworld it was
destroyed by Galactus and Earth is like
this really important place in the
universe it's kind of at like the
crossroads of Intergalactic travel and
obviously like all these superhumans are
made here uh it's rich in resources it's
a great place a real heliocentric view
of the universe yeah
super important is it important because
we
what's the point Authority Port
Authority in New York City of the
universe yeah exactly exactly everyone
wants to be an earth baby uh and so like
the scholar always trying to get they
show up in the comics like in the 60s
with the Fantastic Four and they have to
deal with them they turn into cows it's
a lot of fun uh but at one point like
right before the secret Invasion event
there's like the acree scroll War Earth
kind of gets sucked into it a little bit
they don't want to deal with it so the
Illuminati go to this where the
squirrels are hanging out and they're
like don't come back to earth anymore
stop [ __ ] around with us okay and
while they're there though the
Illuminati get captured and they get
like experimented on by the scroll by
the Scrolls and they get free and that's
how the skulls learn how to make like
powered Scrolls right that can then
replace other superhumans that sets it
on a course uh and then eventually you
have the reveal that the Scrolls have
replaced people and that's done by uh
Spider Woman uh Jessica Jennifer Drew
Jessica Jessica Drew thank you Jessica
Clement Jessica Clements uh Jessica
Clement Jessica Electra electric gets
killed and she reverts into scroll form
so a spider woman takes that to Iron Man
and Iron Man's like whoa holy [ __ ] we
got a problem on our hands uh there's
skulls everywhere whether he doesn't
know at the time is that Spider Woman is
also a scroll she's uh this character
princess Veronica who had a vision that
the skulls were going to be killed off
and so she's like we got to set off this
whole Invasion plan but she revealed you
might ask why would a secret scroll
reveal that there are Scrolls on Earth
isn't that foiling the plan but it's not
she does that on purpose to start the
paranoia train because immediately like
The Avengers get back together they're
split up this at this part because of
Civil War and they're like they're
Scrolls everywhere we gotta deal with
this and Neymar's like well you could
all be skrulls and they're like well you
could be a scrub it's like they split up
and they're like like John Carpenter's
The Thing yeah you know and so it gets
revealed that basically the squirrels
have infiltrated every team that exists
because in the comics there's like a
team of Avengers in every state uh and
oh there's one everywhere there's a
skull everywhere there's a squirrels in
wakanda there's girls on the illuminae
the Scrolls hidden everywhere a lot of
characters get revealed to be Scrolls
and this is what's interesting to look
at the MCU and how much of the story
they're going to take because a lot of
the characters that were Scrolls in the
comics don't exist in the MCU yet
Spider-Woman blackboat we saw in a
different University he's not in 616 as
far as we know Elektra again Netflix but
they kind of killed her on that uh
various Agents of Shield are revealed to
be Scrolls the big ones are like Jarvis
it's revealed to be scrum now Jarvis
isn't alive uh in anymore in the MCU but
it could mean someone close to Iron Man
as a skull yeah dumb dumb Duggan who
we're going to come back we're going to
come back to that though yeah later
aren't we bro uh is this called the male
Captain Marvel Marvel is revealed to be
a scroll Mockingbird uh who some have
speculated could be uh uh Clint Barton's
wife could be Mockingbird in the MCU
shushin's about to be a scroll some of
the big interesting ones Hank Pym turns
out to be a scroll that's a big reveal
very very freaky and also also the
Contessa Val is a straw uh and that's a
big one to me because like Val is a very
new character she's putting together
this team of Heroes we don't know who
she works for yet that has not really
been revealed it's assumed the
government in some aspects but like if
she turns out to be a scroll that could
be a big deal because Valen Nick Fury
fight they're against odds in the comics
because of the scroll Invasion but is
that something they could be setting up
here is that our biggest clue well and
well we can see interesting we have not
seen or heard any casting of Julia
Louis-Dreyfus her vowel being in secret
Invasion no and we know she's gonna be
in Thunderball and there might be some
speculation that we know Olivia Coleman
is going to be in secret Invasion she
might be playing a similar role to what
Val would have been playing yeah she's
she's playing a character who's the
daughter of Captain Britain or
granddaughter I forget uh I thought it
was Grand all I know is that she's close
with she's in the same family same
family well and and uh so one thing
we've been speculating about and we're
going to get to this later who's some of
our strongest thoughts are of who might
be a scroll is you know it's important
in a thing like this where there's shape
shifters and whatever it can't only be
brand new characters that they're
introducing that's no fun that's not as
much fun if like
um you know somebody who's being
introduced for the first time in secret
Invasion turns out to be a scroll that's
fine there'll probably be some of those
but we need some OG MCU characters to
also have been Australia the thing is
it'd be so stupid of them to do that if
it's someone that's like dead if it's
someone that's if someone came out and
was like I'm Iron Man I'd be like that's
a small
big ones uh one of my characters which
we'll get into later I think is one of
those older characters that could bring
brought back also I do think it gives
way to give like I would love for the
queen scroll to be Jessica Drew to be
Spider Woman because there could be that
just that question of like oh yeah
remember every time the universe has
broken and other people have gone to
different places this would make sense
that one of the Spider-Mans have fallen
into ours and now we have a Jessica Drew
yeah because you can imagine if you're a
scroll wait waiting to become an
effective sleeper agent on Earth you're
going to wait for some kind of crazy
thing to happen maybe you're walking
down the street and you see a dead
Spider Woman and you're like I'll try
I'll throw her in the river and I'll
take her place okay
if you see something say something no
unless you're a scroll then you just
sort of bury the body and take it
question type thing yes because I
started researching secret Invasion
before coming here because I knew that
was today's topic oh what a what a guy I
started I didn't finish so it's long
it's a long long event so I saw that
when the Illuminati figured out that
there were Scrolls and they were
examining the body of the scroll that
was impersonating Elektra right they
figured out that no magic no technology
could have detected yeah because they
had kind of harvested the Illuminati
before
uh so is that accurate like squirrels
biologically look too much like compared
to the radar even people that are
teleporting yeah it's too easy if
there's like a black light for like
detecting yourself
in uh Captain Marvel they're like you're
answering some questions yes I know if
you're scrolling well there's a part in
the comics where I think they which I
don't quote me on this it's been a
minute but I think there was a part
where Scarlett Johansson's Black Widow
just shot someone and you could see
green come off and they were like yeah
we're just gonna start shooting everyone
and whoever bleeds real blood is a human
whoever bleeds green is a scroll yeah
and I was like honestly
you are and write that in the comics
that can't detect them and Reed Richards
actually comes up with a way to detect
Scrolls so he makes me laugh but doesn't
he knows it right after he does it they
don't I forget they don't kill him it
was what's his name I thought Hank Pym
as the squad
technology uh and it's something they
could do here it's also important to
note that like the scroll uh the skulls
that replace Heroes don't always kill
the heroes uh they're later revealed to
like come back they're like oh we were
trapped away and they had replaced us
like Mockingbird who they thought was
dead and then came back as a scroll was
actually still alive and they bring her
back right uh things like that happen
the skulls are also there for a long
time and they allow a lot of the big
events leading up to secret Invasion to
happen they don't stop it like House of
them they see it happening and they're
like oh this is good because this will
get rid of the Scarlet Witch we don't
have to worry about that uh there's
another event called secret war and
that's Secret Wars but secret war that
they kind of allow to happen uh because
it it's good for them it helps thin out
the superhero heard right so if you look
at that with the MCU it'd be great if
they've been planning this for a long
time and it's like oh like they allowed
uh the snap to happen or so like they
were helping Thanos get his stones or
like they helped with the invasion of
New York to make sure that like Loki
could get in or like they helped with
Tiamat yes crusting out of the ground
someone's gonna die or a lot of people
are gonna die and they should but I got
something can scroll mimic powers there
are super Scrolls that can mimic Powers
so far in the MCU we have not seen we've
not seen that now but that could be
introduced right like because the in the
Captain Marvel when we were introduced
to Scrolls in the MCU which that means
Scrolls have been on Earth since the 90s
right at least at least since the 90s
it's true
um yeah we don't see them I mean they
seem pretty agile in like good Fighters
but nobody's shooting lasers or anything
right no no confront powers and there's
also Scrolls that can do magic that can
tap into like eldric magic and do that
kind of stuff it's also you know uh
Captain Marvel the big twist going into
that movie was we all assume the Scrolls
would be evil as they often are
portrayed in the comics but they were
all like good well-intentioned Scrolls
and it's like why are there is there now
a problem is this a different faction of
skull are these Older scrolls that were
here before and they're like get these
images
two things they're Scrolls they can also
combine the powers of two people and it
doesn't really intentionally work
because there's people that are like
Wolverine which they can't recreate the
adamantium
so it's like there's Scrolls that can be
like I'm gonna take the skin of Beast
yeah
I'm gonna take the powers of Spider-Man
so it's like you'll know which ones are
wrong because it's like this yeah
Wolverine claws and like Nightcrawler
yeah
Doctor Strange like freaking Cape but
it's like flying like Captain Marvel
yeah it's like when you get an action
figure from the dollar store yeah it's a
wish superhero yeah yeah yeah yeah uh
but yeah I would love that if it was
later revealed that a lot of these bad
events in the MCU were because of the
scroll and pushing it down we know right
there's a small group of Scrolls that
made it to Earth in the 90s but we know
from that post credit scene Nick Fury is
up there on that space station with a
lot of Scrolls yeah and I seem to all be
getting along that's my biggest like I
can't wait to see Nick Fury in this
because Nick Fury is going to be the
most what is it called when you're like
paranoid person he's gonna be the most
paranoid he's like I don't trust anyone
and then this is like I definitely don't
trust anyone so he's just gonna be a
freaking man is he gonna fake die again
so I think he's a fake I saw that in the
one of the big catalysts was uh sword
got blown up by squirrel yes so that'll
probably kick off that'll be the
probably be the thing that yeah maybe
that's what brings him back to Earth
yeah right is like uh that gets blown up
and maybe that like hints at like a
scroll separatist movement right like
hey we can't keep getting along with
these humans we need to take over Earth
there's a faction within the Scrolls
right look here we can't get along with
the humans anymore that that party's
gonna be great
Fast and Furious that James Cameron
going after him first uh Scrolls contain
multitudes just like all other peoples
yeah no no any any no any group of
people is good or bad girls are not a
monolith that's right that's right
with me and Brandon who think all
schools are bad all schools are bad hey
Cass
ASAP
ASAP uh ASAP Rocky like the car well all
the Scrolls may be bad but what's not
bad is athletic greens hey we want to
thank them for being a sponsor today uh
we're all big fans of ag-1 which is like
their main product I'm a big fan of it I
drink it every day it's a very easy way
to get all of your daily nutrition look
at this tasty boy right here every scoop
of ag-1 has 75 high quality vitamins
minerals oh food source superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens uh it's great
stuff it's it's good for you it'll help
with your Sleep Quality your mental
Clarity your exercise recovery if you
exercise I totally do uh ag1 is the one
thing you can do it for yourself every
single day to take great care of
yourself reclaim your health and arm
your immune system with convenient daily
nutrition it's just one scoop of ag1 and
a cup of water every day that's it uh
it's well maintains product they do a
lot of research into it it's made well
it's made safely it's good for you uh
and they also do things like they help
with programs like no kid hungry uh and
other stuff like that so it's a great
product and we really appreciate them
sponsoring the show uh and they want to
hook you guys up uh with a your supply
of vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase and all you
have to do to get that awesome deal is
visit athleticgreens.com break room
again that is athleticgreens.com break
room to take ownership over your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional yeah I wanna I wanna tease a
few things a we have hit a Super Chat
threshold so we will be releasing a
torrent of dag nasty James Cameron
I'll say we have a very special guest
waiting in the wings
um he's staring daggers at me right now
okay he'll be here more material he
might even help us with some of these
James Cameron porn puns uh but before we
get to that we also want to shout out
the other folks helping bring this show
to you Land's End uh hey we don't like
Uh crap swag boom crap okay swag you
know from watching the show a good 80 of
my wardrobe is free stuff that I've been
given at some point I don't ever spend
this is one of the few shirts I've
bought in the last five years
um but even free stuff is not good when
it's poor quality you know and you if
you're responsible for making the swag
for your company maybe for an event a
convention a holiday whatever you need
to be getting good swag from our friends
at Lands End Business okay they make
fully customized clothes accessories and
promotional products featuring your logo
your company colors all that and it's
elevated by their Decades of experience
making great hearty good clothing uh
they offer timeless style it fits
everybody type the widest ranges of
sizes you'll find in branded apparel
hundreds of products perfect for any
trade show event or holiday gift if
customer service that goes above and
beyond you get treated like a VIP you
know what whether you're a tiny company
like new rockstars or some Fortune 500
uh big wig
um you don't need to worry about it
they're taking good care of you you see
why thousands of companies count on
lands and business go to business go to
business dot lands end.com slash podcast
that's right slash podcast the link is
in those videos description and use
promo code podcast you might be watching
the show on YouTube but the promo code
is podcast 25 off your first product
that's
business.landsand.com podcast promo code
podcast for 25 off your first product
now
I think we've got I think it's time for
our special guest if he wants to join
from mandatory
no you're fine I'll stand up
by the way crap swag and I headlined
rolling loud 2017. uh Wired Magazine
said the set was what's what's rolling
Lounge oh it's a music festival I'm not
cool I don't know what things are he
just rolled up one in his house it
doesn't make me automatically cool true
we are excited for secret invasion in
the revelation of who's been hiding on
Earth as a Scrolls
who has been hiding on Earth as a scroll
don't give me that little bird-legged
chair John that can't support the weight
of my talent
off this chair oh yes I'll use the X-Men
Storm Tommy uh what's the um what's the
reasoning behind your cape I was just
about to okay
I'm sorry baby no that was my fault I
need you in a tie all right now
according to clueless
towards you in them
let's do that with HR uh oh cape's
falling off too close
crap swag you can put your leg down and
then in I'm good right here I'm posing
like a high school portrait
we are excited
comma waiting for secret invasion in the
revelation of who has been hiding on
Earth as a scroll today we're going to
pitch our most detailed conclusions for
what I like to call scroll search 2020.
[Music]
we each got our candidates but I thought
you know what I'm wearing a backwards
hat like a cool team and I forgot to
turn forward before this moment I just
realized it was still sitting nope it's
too late now it's tucked into my hair
plugs
sorry the Trap flag was giving me a
manicure and I slapped him across his
crappy face anyway uh so we're gonna
turn this into a bit of a model uh
Global Protection Agency a model GPA
okay we're gonna do this high school
rules the gentleman from Florida the
gentleman from Florida the gentle woman
from Washington the gentleman from
Maryland now and of course
I'm that boss from Rochester
you get the city
and your professor
Professor he doesn't claim Yonkers or I
don't think Brighton Beach
Albany who's the biggest little city in
the world that's Reno the city that
never sleeps don't care about it the
flower city is what I care about Buffalo
an All-American City or Ithaca which is
gorgeous what's Washington
what do they call Washington the mistake
have you played the graphic at all oh no
hit the graphic oh there it is
finally I can rest predatory fund the
segment so unexpected that we play the
graphic unaffected
it's time for mandatory front the
segment without a boss come back here
Eric
Show Yourself
monsters
[Music]
now uh Eric is Eric would be joining us
but he is very busy making the Andor
breakdown they'll be coming out don't
make excuses also thank you guys for
knowing what the Washington if you Super
Chat 100 right now I'll make them come
back tomorrow
I'm not kidding all right now we're
gonna pitch our potential Scrolls but
we're gonna do it like dignified adults
okay for once on this show
okay so each of you has selected a
scroll or a person currently in the MCU
that we believe will reveal themselves
as a scroll we will be allowed to rebut
and then I will make my final decision
as Professor bechtold will the gentleman
from Florida please absolutely thank you
for calling me a gentleman I've worked
hard to attain that status
um here I I this is my um Zack daddy
guarantee okay this is a locks this is
the only of all the people that are
going to speak the only person that's
guaranteed 100 to be right I know for a
fact what one of the characters on the
show that will be a scroll Emilia
Clark's character uh Abigail brand
hearsay is a scroll okay so we know we
know
what is this the House of Lords
um we know Emilia and Clark's been
casting this show but they've been very
purposefully vague there's a whole thing
a few weeks ago where like a gif an
official gift site kind of accidentally
leaked that she'd be playing Abigail
brand and Disney has gone out of their
way to like grab that from the internet
my gift sites never leak stuff like that
but they do show leaks
like the plant oh yes yeah yeah like the
like the onion Style
by the way by the way should we pause
real quick and do 60 seconds of James
Cameron it'll be quick yeah yeah John
can we put up the clock again this comes
out of his rebuttal time okay that's
fine it's worth it we gotta we gotta
redeem uh the the super chats again
we're gonna do 60 seconds of James
Cameron film porn parodies in honor of
him doing a press tour for avatar The
Way of the water do we have the
yeah okay uh Titanic ah I got Titanic
acitar yeah oh I think I'm stealing this
from Brandon uh true size oh fascinator
fudgment day that's the star two the way
of Charter
what else has he done dark X Angel oh
my god oh um the a piss oh yes all right
a lot of Sports Action
[ __ ] licker
[Music]
back for tomorrow maybe we'll get him
back on the show today uh and you have
now redeemed for the next level so we'll
we'll finish this mandatory fun and then
we're gonna come back we'll end the show
with at least a minute of MCU porn
parody titles uh there's a lot more to
choose from than James Cameron films so
we'll go we're doing MCU I like that
yeah we're switching the genre I just
want to give a nice little shout out to
the Virgil uh that said oh no scroll up
scroll up
said
Terminator booty day
no no can I I don't mean to come in here
halfway three quarters of the way
through the episode can we make it all
superhero movies because I've learned
through a lot of MCU okay
yes uh so you can include the DCU or how
about horror films cream cream two cream
three four what's that a spin-off though
uh wow Nina you throwing another 50. I
think we're gonna need to give them
maybe a solid two minutes of porn
parodies which we have it in us we
easily could just do movies uh okay but
let me finish Abigail brand so we we've
gotten kind of inadvertent confirmation
that's who Amelia Clark will be playing
Abigail brand in the comics now it's not
a scroll but she is half alien half
human she plays a big role especially in
the early parts of the secret Invasion
comic storyline she's kind of aligned
with the humans uh helping to out the
Scrolls and like
um uh she kind of helps Mr Fantastic
escape from being imprisoned at one
point
Etc et cetera now they're obviously
going to change her storyline a lot in
this series
um but I think she's going to be a
scroll I think she's going to be a good
scroll though and she can squirrel in
the comics whatever she's half like some
other alien race she was born I think it
was called uh axis was the planet she's
from not like a known race though she
looks like a human but um uh much like
Emilia Clarke does but I think they're
going to reveal she's Emily Clark
confirmed he looks like a human very
human very human-like uh human confirmed
uh so that that is my pitch my zag daddy
100 lock confirmed scroll wow nice I
like that would any of the gentlemen or
women like to push back on that well I
will say this gentleman is the one who
said that this show should not have new
characters be Scrolls wow here he is
locking in a scroll of the Zone Wow
Let's make my decision
scroll Caesar says
she's a scroll oh yeah so as girl Caesar
are you a scroll who's I wouldn't dig
too deep into scroll Caesar's origin
story it's a bit of a thin love your
salad yeah love your salad girl Caesar
love your hotel in Vegas squirrel
Caesars is where your satisfaction is
never guaranteed the gentleman from
Maryland will you please pitch your
scroll yes I shall thank you uh wow
so I would like to say that James Rhodes
won war machine will be a scroll in
secret Invasion the Disney plus TV show
in the trailer he asked too many goddamn
questions and that is typical scroll
Behavior
what do we don't what do we not know
someone in my ranks is a scroll move
what and he's a very uh impactful
powerful person especially in the US
government oh okay and with superheroes
okay and the government alike he is kind
of the Emissary Emissary of the two he's
not Howard so it's easier to mimic him
you're saying scroll whole time or was
he replaced at some point replace at
some point yeah that's definitely him as
Terrence Howard and Iron Man won between
then he's not wrong
when his back broke then
they really know how to keep their form
together until death that's right now
what if James Rhodes died then and then
a squirrel came in and replaced him and
the Morrigan was like oh I'm alive but
my legs oh my God our Roadie died in
Civil War makes that movie so much even
sad or I thought he did die in the movie
and then when they showed him at the end
I was like oh I guess he's alive bro
that was fascinating that was a
fascinating one we all kind of pushed
back on that but uh I like it though
yeah we mostly liked it
off we all offered uh
scroll Caesar says I'm in charge oh now
I know he's actually gonna be a squirrel
Caesar does this fart I think you did
great squirrel Caesar doesn't have a
butthole so you can't oh it's you make
sure you didn't have a bottle that's his
backstory like I said there's not a lot
there but that's fair it is fascinating
that's a good that's a true back story
if a scroll sees a human to replicate
but they're wearing clothes do they know
what to do Under the clothes like
does it automatically these rifles are
too big yeah yeah or like because we
know we know they transformed the
clothing
yeah bring a hill nipples the size of
children's dinner which also
I am becoming her sorry they mimic the
clothing how do they take their clothes
off their clothes off at some point
Maria Hills boyfriends or girlfriend is
like something's different
um
too many nipples quick very quick aside
could be smaller the actress that plays
Maria Hill I was at a restaurant with
her the other day not with her she was
in the same restaurant
and you know she's married to tear and
kill him
anyways they have a couple of children
together oh that's so wonderful uh I I a
big fan of both of them and if they're
listening come on come on the show
uh okay the gentlewoman from Washington
who would you like to present I think
I'm sorry I'm gonna immediately
let's get on here oh no oh okay oh uh I
think Baron Zemo is a scroll I think he
got a million and two opportunities to
become a scroll and I think it's when he
went to prison the first time
oh they swapped him out I don't know
where the real one is the real one is
probably on board with it and is gone
well yeah
so the scroll schemos
sorry to interrupt no no I agree with
you I agree with you I think Baron Zemo
is a scroll and I think it's after he
went to prison I think uh especially
after we learned that he has his own
brand of vodka I think that he's been
putting stuff literally in the water
he's been putting things in there and
he's trying to get into all of us he has
his own brand of vodka yeah well it was
actually I shouldn't say clearly we know
it was brought up and uh assembled it
was their assembled episode they had a
featurette that was Baron zemo's vodka
and it was for like Smooth daddies that
liked vodka also can you see a great
scene in secret Invasion where cut to
Zemo in a wakanda prison and he just
like transforms out of Zemo and is able
to Escape right he transforms into a
prison guard and that helps him get out
or whatever right well there's no powers
that has to be controlled and also
they've been doing pretty good job of
making their way into the system with
working with Brody or not Brody working
with Falcon in the Winter Soldier in
Falcon in the Winter Soldier I think
he's like oh I'm getting I'm getting in
I now know who the power broker is I'm
getting in there we're gonna we're gonna
destroy them all okay and this third
works with your theory timing or scroll
Caesar whoever you are that uh that ever
K Ross is doomed because ever cray Ross
initially is the one who confronted Zemo
in prison at the end of Civil War and
could have been like I have an offer for
you he was like I want to swap you out
here it is it's someone who's been there
from the beginning they're very close to
a very powerful person inside the MCU
happy Hogan
but here's the thing he's a good scroll
okay when the squirrels we saw in
Captain Marvel arrived there's four of
them uh some of them we go on
unaccounted for uh uh and there's this
pivotal moment when they land in the
water they come out they see a woman
with a surfboard uh that two of them
change into that woman one of them being
Talos another one being another's girl
and Talus is like no I claim the woman
get out of here later on in Far From
Home happy Hogan calls Nick Fury who is
a scroll at that time who's tallest the
scroll and he's warning him about
Mysterio and he's telling him like
things aren't the way they seem but one
thing he says in there is that like I
was moving all this stuff out and they
found a surfboard and they're like who's
the surfboard belong to Nick Fury why
does it say surfboard because that was
the first thing that him in Tallahassee
that's their keyword and then uh uh uh
Nick Fury knew that he had to keep
someone close to Howard Stark and Tony
Stark because they were going to be
important helped implant happy Halloween
and then Happy Hogan gets to bang out
man he's like I'm the luckiest
baby happy hug and scroll scroll Caesar
says
no freaking
out
and of course I don't even have to do
mine as an argument because we're
running out of time Sharon Carter oh wow
but she's not only against the scroll
she's princess oh
yes uh thank you uh uh scroll Caesar
and thank you real quick so we're about
to do our final Redemption as we uh say
goodbye here thank you to Quentin
Christian unpronounceable Bucky Barnes
ATL uh Michael she is saying hello to
the break room from Disney World what
are you writing right now what are you
eating which Park are you at are you
typing on the teacups uh Nina you b b l
uh 69 hotep films everybody TD Jones
everybody that that helped contributes
now uh John if we can put a clock up
we're gonna do two minutes of superhero
film porn parody because we hit 300.
yeah so we're gonna do two minutes we're
gonna explore and we might even throw in
some lines of dogs it can be other
superheroes any superhero movie you
might give you some lines of dialogue
maybe act out some scenes uh fully
closed
um
and we're and we're off uh uh uh my
favorite porn category black widows oh
my God it's just black widows okay
thrusters League The Miner cut
uh here we go black panther yeah
a frosted Soldier uh Black Panther
wakanda for dinner
black panther will come around here
forever internals
[Laughter]
I don't like that
absolutely I mean that is a specific job
all right all right a little obscure but
a different comic book movie Jonah sex
oh yeah oh I got one Hitchcock doesn't
even need a pot there it is the [ __ ]
Patrol yeah how about um uh food Patrol
I said it's fun spun oh yes
punicide Squad
Suicide Squad
[Laughter]
how about this just do it Thor the pork
world oh that's a good one Thor 11
cumber
um
Wang Wang Chi and the legend of the [ __ ]
rings yeah
[Laughter]
I guess this might be too much but uh
cockman and gasp yeah
yeah
falcomm and the in her Soldier
uh oh let's see
come on come on decision
yes
[Music]
okay that's fine